au mois déjà la ville de pékin n'est
plus qu'à un immense chantier les vieux
quartiers sont entièrement détruits les
habitants expulsés en échange
d'indemnisations ridicule claude son
père sylvain guillaume c'est chaque jour
la même chose
dix huit heures du matin les pelleteuses
rentrer en action et détruisent les
maisons l'une après l'autre devant des
habitants impuissants
c'est très dur pour les gens du peuple
moi je suis au chômage je n'ai plus
d'argent et ils vont détruire ma maison
j'ai passé 25 ans en partie et ça ne
compte pas il est pas assez indemnisés
il nous donne pas assez d'argent avec ça
on peut pas se reloger
nous sommes en plein centre de pékin
à 200 mètres de la place tienanmen un
quartier historique avec des ruelles qui
ont parfois plus de 600 ans
aujourd'hui partout des engins de
travaux publics qui détruisent tout pour
laisser la place au nouveau pékin sur
les murs quelques banderoles qui parle
de la nécessité de construire une
nouvelle vie pour les jeux olympiques de
au milieu des gravats ils sont
quelques-uns refusé de partir mais de
jour en jour leurs conditions de vie
sont de plus en plus difficile
moi je ne l'avais pas donner un accord
je n'avais rien signé et ils sont venus
tout détruire chez moi alors que je
n'étais pas là pékin ressemble
aujourd'hui un immense chantier de
travaux publics
à deux ans des jeux olympiques de
nouveaux immeubles sortent de terre tous
les mois les propriétaires des vieux
quartiers reçoit 800 euros d'indemnités
par mètre carré
une somme très faible à la place de
leurs maisons construit des hôtels de
luxe et des galeries marchandes les
terrains sont revendus plusieurs
millions d'euros la spéculation règne en
maître
la surface des terrains rasé à pékin
représente un espace aussi grand paris
chaque jour des centaines de personnes
sont expulsées parfois par la force
pas une ligne dans la presse pas de
procès devant les tribunaux ici le parti
a toujours raison et personne ne peut
contester ses décisions